do you know what talking thrones is a
YouTube channel just waiting for people
to come along and watch it like a
Valyrian steel sword sharp and unfilled
with videos ready to be shared talking
thrones isn't a bit talking throne
Salada then you try to top it fail never
get to try again the theories and
predictions break them some are given
the chance to watch they refuse telling
devoured gas or other channels the
talking throws is all there is
what's up ladies and gentlemen let's get
right into it today I want to talk about
the night King his strength potential
weaknesses and what it's going to take
to defeat him if you've been a
subscriber of mine since the beginning
then you probably remember me discussing
this once before in one of my very first
videos but there are a few other things
I need to mention plus I want to show
you a few interesting comments that were
left on my previous video this video is
going to be meant for the show only
simply because the night's king and the
books is completely different in many
ways from the night King and the show
either way we really don't know that
much about him at all we did get a quick
origin story though during season six
when bran was in the three-eyed Ravens
cave we learned that the children of the
forest were at war and they needed help
so they created the night King by
plunging a dragonglass dagger into his
heart but that's all we saw we don't
actually know how many the children are
the force created but we do know that
the night king has the ability to create
White Walkers by using Craster's newborn
babies a simple touch to the cheek with
his finger and there you have it ladies
and gentlemen another super powerful
soldier fighting for the others we also
know that the night king can raise the
dead who are at the bottom tier of his
army more or less his foot soldiers that
do all the grunt work then you have the
White Walkers who are second in command
that take care of the night kings more
sensitive missions like obtaining
Craster's kids and being the knight
King's right-hand men then you have the
night King the most powerful of them all
which he has displayed that he has
several different superhuman powers in
the show not only can the knight king
create White Walkers and raise the dead
but he also seems to have some sort of
greenseer ability and worgen ability
similar to brand but at this point even
more powerful than brand at least until
brand learns how to harness his powers
but the knight King also has superhuman
strength after he marked bran he knew
that he was in a three-eyed Ravens cave
and just by touching the ground he was
able to shatter the ground a knife that
rocked the cave almost like causing a
small earthquake we've also seen just
how strong the White Walkers are too so
we can only imagine how strong the
knight king must be and with one
bitch-slap the White Walkers sent Sam
flying through the air and we also saw
the white Walker at hardhome thrown
around like he
a rag doll the interesting thing about
the White Walkers is they do seem to
have a mind of their own
unlike the whites who are just your
average soldiers for the night King that
all seemed to work in unison with the
night King which we saw a perfect
example of that in brains vision when
brain entered the vision the whites were
all standing in formation almost looking
as if they were frozen in time as bran
broke through the ranks and approached
the night King they all stood perfectly
still which at first made it seem like
he was in a dream state of mind until he
reached an eye King when the night King
turned his head to look at bran
all of a sudden all of the whites were
now turned around facing brand as if
they were just waiting for the night
King to command them to attack but the
White Walkers don't seem to be under
that same spell although I do think the
night King could control them if he
wanted to you can tell they are very
methodical and strategic in the way they
move unlike the whites who do seem to be
like zombies even though Dan and Dave
said they are not zombies but we've seen
the night King in the White Walkers show
emotion several times which lets me know
they aren't just mindless beings sent to
destroy humanity they do have a
conscience we saw at least two instances
of this at Hart home while Jon Snow was
fighting the white Walker he was able to
stop the white Walker from killing him
thanks to his Valyrian steel sword
Longclaw one of my favorite moments in
this episode was the look on the White
Walkers face when he realized he made a
big mistake allowing John to get to his
sword he was an utter shock in disbelief
that someone or something could stop him
from carving through John like a hot
knife through butter then the very next
moment we see the night king overlooking
the battlefield in he too sees John
defeat one of his top lieutenants the
night king was very intrigued by this
you know he was thinking something
wondering who this man was and how he
was able to kill a white Walker like
that he definitely showed some interest
in Jon Snow people have also been
wondering if the others have some kind
of culture if they are just these
mindless zombies on a path of death and
destruction I think they do have some
sort of civilized culture outside of
what we see when they're tearing through
towns and villages I don't necessarily
think they're sitting around playing
cards but the knight King obviously has
some sort of plan he does have a motive
I think the night King and his
lieutenants do strategize their attacks
george RR martin also said that there is
no holy good or wholly evil characters
in that story so for anyone to assume
that the night king is the ultimate evil
or villain would be wrong he's just as
much a great character as anyone else
although the show tends to make them out
to be the number one bad guys in this
story but I do understand people wanting
them to lose we do relate to humans so
most people should want the humans to
win in the end
I would prefer to see my favorite
characters live and right now none of
those are on the team of the others but
in order for them to do so it appears
they're going to have to kill the night
king it does not look like he wants to
broker some kind of peace treaty so for
this to happen
it looks like this will end in a hall
out war but how will Jon Snow and
Daenerys and everyone else be able to
defeat a force of this size for all we
know the night King could easily have a
million man army plus he can raise dead
animals we've seen him in the White
Walkers riding with their dead horses so
I'm assuming he can raise other dead
animals too we could even see summer
come back as a white dire wolf since it
was killed in the three-eyed Ravens cave
north of the wall it's hard to say how
many men have died north of the wall
that the knight king can now have
marching in his army but we know that
man planned on to breach the wall and he
said he had a hundred thousand men in
his camp and only probably less than 10
percent of them actually made it south
of the wall alive so the knight came
more than likely has the rest of those
in his army now so even though Daenerys
has three large dragons when you're
fighting an army of that size they're
still going to be very hard to defeat
who knows what else this man can do plus
we know dragons can be killed if you hit
one of them in the eye it's over Johnny
that's not going to be easy to do though
but if you have an army the size of the
knight kings and they're all launching
[ __ ] at these dragons eventually one of
them is going to get lucky but at some
point I do think Jon Snow is going to
face off against the night king one
verse one
those two shared a moment at hardhome
with that epic intense stare down and
you know we're going to get a payoff
scene with those two going head to head
on the battlefield remember this is
going to be on television not in the
books dan and Dave have been known to do
some corny [ __ ] though but
I do think the final battle will be epic
and cinematic with a final showdown this
does happen and Jon Snow does become the
hero who saves humanity even if he does
have to sacrifice himself how is he
going to be able to defeat the night
king if they go head-to-head on the
battlefield
well Valyrian steel be enough to defeat
the most powerful character we have ever
seen this far I don't think so I don't
think Juan Klaw is going to be enough
nor do I think dragonglass can kill him
I don't even think regular fire can stop
him or melt him at this point we know
the weights can be killed with fire and
we know the White Walkers can be killed
with Valyrian steel and dragonglass
but we do not know what can kill the
night King he does appear to be made out
of ice as well but considering how much
more powerful he is than anyone else in
his army I do not think he can be killed
the same way for some reason I have this
image in my head that the 19 can shatter
Valyrian steel just like any other steel
I think if someone tries to kill the
night king with just any Valyrian steel
sword they're going to be very
disappointed at the results if there is
one sword that's going to be able to
kill him then it obviously needs to be
Lightbringer the sword of all sorts the
boss of all bosses which I do think
we're going to get in the show the
flaming sword has been referenced many
times and we've even seen a few
imitators I think if there's going to be
one sword to kill him then it must be
Lightbringer and I do not think light
bringer is going to be Longclaw that
swords probably going to end up back in
the hands of the Mormont one way or
another but another thing that could
potentially kill the night king is a
dragon we have seen the night king and
even the White Walkers have walked right
through fire before not only do they
walk through the fire but they basically
put out the fire just because of how
cold they are so I do not think they can
be killed but fire like a regular
run-of-the-mill white can which makes
sense because the night King and White
Walkers are more powerful than the
whites and since the night King is the
most powerful of them all then I think
it's going to take something serious to
stop him
dragonglass isn't going to be enough but
Dragon Fire might just do the job but I
still feel like we could see this end
with an old-fashioned sword fight I just
wanted to go on record and give my
opinion on this matter because I know
there are people out there that I think
the knight King can be killed the same
way a white Walker can but I don't
believe that at all but before I go
there are two comments that I want to
show you that was left on one of my very
first videos I made
when I talked about the battle against
the night king before Chris said the
only way to kill the night king is to
remove the dragon glass from his chest
now I thought this was a very
interesting idea something I haven't
heard before so I want to show everyone
and get your opinion on it all so
LaDonna said brains mind has to control
the night King while John takes him down
physically the dragons are going to burn
the whites but brain is the one who's
going to have a metaphysical battle of
the minds with the night King I
absolutely love this idea this was also
something that I haven't considered
brain would have to take control of the
night Kings mind that way John is able
to deliver that fatal blow I don't know
if that's how it's going to go down or
not but it would be an interesting way
to do this but comment below and tell me
what you think about all this I'm very
curious to see what other good ideas
some of you may have that I will feature
in another video if this discussion ever
comes up again I want to give a huge
shout out to everyone that I showed
their support to me in the channel over
on patreon I really appreciate you
making donations to the channel I want
to buy a really good camera that way I
can start going on camera when the new
season begins instead of using this
shitty webcam so every dollar you
generous people I've donated will be
going towards a new HD camera thank you
to Kyle spooking chickens Dawn of Ice
and Fire
the Theon defense squad aka Britt in the
sports car podcast
James Millar Jean the marine keyring D
1996 marine Kerry solar cipher and Sir
Thomas thank you all so much I'll see
you down in the comment section bye